in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jeremy
and Tara are with us hey guys welcome
welcome good to have you thank you where
are you guys from
we're from Pella Iowa which is near
just south of Des Moines oh okay very
cool welcome to Nashville Merry
Christmas good to have you guys
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much have you paid off we've
paid off
sixty-eight thousand good deal how long
did that take twenty six months good job
making what kind of money started around
95 and we're making about 115 now 115 15
good very cool
and what do you guys do for a living
Tara well I'm a full-time at home mom
and part-time massage therapist and
part-time volleyball coach that'll work
yeah member of a stay-at-home moms Club
I tell her if he/she gets another job
she's gotta get kicked out well she's
busy yeah keep it that way and what do
you do Jeremy I'm an electrical manager
at a power plant okay very cool good for
you guys so what kind of debt was this
sixty eight thousand dollars everything
two cars credit cards we even had our
couch
on a credit card and I don't even like
the couch Dave don't you like the couch
what's wrong with that
it doesn't fit me well I'm a big guy it
doesn't do it oh it's a little guy couch
no I don't like the little guy couches
either they're no fun I bought a couch
one time without ever having sat on it
and we kept it like two months because
it was the worst thing it was awful I
think we gave it away just about it was
awful same same deal so I'm a nut about
making sure they're comfortable and big
enough to sit on so you got this the bad
couch on the credit card you guys are
just normal weren't you yeah so what
happened 26 months ago - cause you do
this radical life change well he's been
listening to you for a long time but I
haven't wasn't I guess and my business
partner and I she mentioned it to me one
time that she was going to buy Financial
Peace University and they're gonna do at
home with another couple and I just
wanted to know if we were interested and
I thought well this is this is kind of
cool let me ask my husband and of course
he was
well yeah before it and I think from
from his we just we made a decent amount
of money but we didn't pay attention to
our spending and it was adding up I
think it was if you think it's
frustrating for him okay so you guys
went through with two other couples at
home yeah little home study program
alright and that was 26 months ago and
that's what started this yeah we did
that and then 12 months ago we went
through the course of the local church
oh you went back okay alright okay when
you're halfway through you can't either
I guess yeah you got a little Red Bull
right there in the middle yeah I got you
very cool so that got the whole thing
started so what was the first night when
you came home from watching the videos
you went okay grown-up time yeah we got
do a budget how'd that meeting go I
think it went good I'm I was really
excited about it but at the same time it
was kind of stressful because just
something I haven't paid much attention
to and it seemed a little overwhelming
but I think it got me excited about
doing a budget mm-hmm yeah I think it
saved everything I mean it really opened
our communication up it was a lot of
stress on me being basically the primary
wage earner and watching us I would I'm
an engineer so I track everything in I
was actually tracking us losing money
every month
I got a graph for it but we're graphing
our death here I got it
Wow so I congratulations it's got to
feel great I mean you're so weird it's
it's surreal I remember that phone call
like it was yesterday and to be down
here as well the phone call when she
called you and said let's do a Financial
Peace University yeah yeah I was driving
home from work actually and it was
something I didn't expect can I come out
of the blue and it felt like some of
those meant to be yeah hey man
very cool very cool so was it now that
you look back on it the last 26 months
has been really tough you've been really
leaning in you had your foot
the pedal you've been more grown-up more
thoughtful about it more intentional
about every dollar and you've probably
sacrificed a lot giving me the numbers
you've given me here to Mabel make that
much happen in 26 months
I mean you aren't playing around you
were beans and rice rice and beans so I
was it harder at the end of it now that
you get to the end of it you look back
was it harder than you thought it was
going to be when you started or easier
than you thought it was going to be when
you started I think I think it was what
I expected except you get in the middle
of it and you kind of feel a little
hopeless I guess the middle part for me
was was hard just like like he said we
had a refresher course last winter and
that really helped yeah kind of ran out
of emotional steam in the middle I think
so yeah um you know at first it was
exciting and then at the end you could
see then the light at the end of the
tunnel
that's exciting we're right there in the
middle is hard that makes sense it's
logical okay yeah I would you know I'd
take our monthly budget out and I'd take
it out several months so I could see
ahead no not you it's just frustrating
watching you know and get one paycheck
and notice you know in 13 more we're
gonna be right here so yeah so what was
the hardest thing you did the most
sacrifice that you did to make this
happen because I don't want people
listening to think this is easy it's not
easy that's why we put you on here and
he'll hail you as heroes because you are
you've sacrificed to win you've changed
your family tree you've changed your
marriage you've changed these kids
future you're weird officially you have
no debt I mean that's rocks and but it's
not easy so what was the hardest part
was she'll probably have a different
answer but the hardest part for me was
that the only good thing I did with
money is I'd been putting a lot into my
401k in retirement and so when you talk
on the videos about discontinuing
contributions to that temporarily well
yeah it felt like an eternity yeah yeah
but no I'd done good on that and
actually through the process you know I
could still you know it's not like it
went anywhere yeah it really felt good
for me to start that up with a month ago
again I bet I bet I think for me was I'm
not a big shot
anyways but we have we had a we had a
nice house but it needs a lot of updates
that we like to do so for instance like
we redid our bathroom and just to be
able to have to budget for the month and
say okay maybe this month we can only
afford to do the floor and then the rest
has to wait to the next month and then
more has to wait the following month and
just to have that patience of mmhmm yeah
yeah let's go get done but it's gonna
take a while yeah yeah it's kind of
weird that discipline when you're doing
it feels really bad but when you look
back on it feels good hmmm it's like
paying a price to win the volleyball
game I mean you do you do the exercise
you do the work you know you do the
practice routines and the whole thing
and then in the game time boom there we
are it's the same kind of a feeling
so excellent you guys very well done all
right Jeremy and Tara now what are your
kids names and ages mrs. Kimsey she's
six and a half and this is Wyatt and
he's four and a half all right have they
been practicing all the way from Des
Moines Iowa all right guys ready Jeremy
and Tara Kenzie and Wyatt are $68,000
paid off in 26 months making 95 to 115
count it down what's there a dent free
scream three two one
it's job you guys
very well done that is exactly how you
do it excellent excellent job very well
done you guys would be so rich so fast
and be able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others
you